hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the first part of Emmanuel K
proma to any future metaphysics he is
concerned with this question how is pure
mathematics possible and by this what
does he mean well mathematics as such
not mathematics necessarily as it's
being taught or applied to physical
things say in engineering or to
particular problems but how is
mathematics as a discipline as a form of
cognition or knowledge Arness how is
this actually going to be possible and K
is you know doing a little bit of a
softball as we call it here a little bit
of a question that already has some sort
of uh presupposed answer you could say
because he knows from his first critique
how indeed it is possible he's discussed
it there and we know that mathematics is
possible because we actually use it but
this question of how
requires a kind of deepening of the
inquiry into what mathematics is and how
it actually works and the key idea here
is going to be that of AR priori
intuitions this is where a lot of people
get tripped up in Reading K whether it's
the proma or the first critique and
thinking about the nature of mathematics
in part because they already have
associations with this term intuition
which is how we translate
Ona uh from German into to English and
so he tells us that
mathematical
cognition must exhibit dellan so that
that stellin term there is going to be
important as we're going to see we're
going to have forell in just a bit must
exhibit its concept it's B in two
important intersecting ways one is it's
got to demonstrate these things a priori
and this is what has attracted so many
people not just to mathematics as
something that's certain definite you
know something we can make progress in
like he says a great and established
branch of knowledge encompassing even
now a wonderfully large domain so past
accomplishments and promising and unlim
extension in the future but it carries
with it thoroughly Optical certainty
that is absolute necessity which
therefore rests on no empirical grounds
and so the Temptation the second part of
that has been to say listen mathematics
is different than other things maybe
there's like a a world of pure Essences
out there that it corresponds to this is
sort of the platonic uh tendency an
interpretation or maybe it's relations
of ideas as David Hume had said but
there's something special about
mathematics and and Kant says well um
we've got some sort of not just a priori
but
exhibiting what it exhibits in an
intuition says it must first exhibit its
concept in intuition an intuition that
is not empiric
but pure so what does empirical mean
based on experience that we have in our
day-to-day sensible world or perhaps
even of our own thought processes right
instead we have a pure intuition and
then you know the question is well what
is that going to be and he goes on and
he says that this pure
intuition um is absolutely necessary for
mathematics without this mathematics
cannot take a single step its judgments
are always intuitive whereas philosophy
must be satisfied with discursive
judgments from Mere Concepts so what
we're doing in mathematics is different
than what we're doing in philosophy but
notice that philosophy can make sense
out of what mathematics is doing and so
he says that you know if we can discuss
this pure intuition and its
possibility then we may easily explain
how synthetic propositions oper possible
in pure mathematics and consequently how
this science itself is possible so some
sort of pure intuition must form the
basis lying at the very ground of pure
mathematics and then he he says well
this is going to you know raise a a
question but first we have to actually
make an important
distinction empirical intuition is what
we're most used to thinking in terms of
and this really subsumes the entirety of
what we're tempted to call intuition
according to K so he says as empirical
intuition enables us without difficulty
to enlarge the concept we frame of an
object of intuition by new predicates
which intuition itself presents
synthetically and experience okay so
what is all of that we don't typically
think about things that way we say well
I look at something and I learn
something new about it right or I taste
something and I find out I like it or
don't like it it's wholesome or it's
it's noxious or something like that
well those things that we say that we
know about it those are new predicates
that we can say about it that we can
have in a judgment or a cognition right
or
a
proposition so that's what he's talking
about and we do this through looking at
things or smelling things or touching
things or a combination of all of these
now of course as he's going to say a
little bit later on the sense perception
the sensability doesn't actually make
the judgments it's the understanding
which forms judgments and and it does so
using that sense data but in other ways
and this is something we're doing all
the time as a matter of fact we've been
doing this essentially since infancy
right so he goes on and he says
um pure intuition also does likewise but
there is a difference in pure intuition
the synthetic judgment is a priori
certain and apodictic now means it can't
be wrong right and it's it's uh
Universal it's demonstrating something
that we can certainly buy into in the
former only aor and empirically certain
because the aor case contains only that
which appears in contingent empirical
intuition but the AR priori case
contains that which must necessarily be
discovered in pure intuition now
necessarily necessarily by Me by you by
any rational being that is constituted
in the way that we are so we've got
empirical a posteriori in intuitions
coming from experience of limited scope
then we have pure a priori intuitions
which are of universal scope you could
say and here somebody might raise a
question as Kant does how is it possible
to intu anything a priori or how are a
priori intuitions even possible some
people might say listen intuitions are
just experience so so you don't get to
call some of them a priori uh that's you
know playing around with with terms and
inventing something that isn't real and
K goes on and he says okay what is an
intuition an intuition is a
representation of forong right so now
we've got our other schellong andell
mean stellin means to place in in in
something right to constitute so for
representations
they could be images they could be you
know various other kinds of ideas forell
that depends on the presence of the
object now the object is the gag andand
and the presence of the object is the uh
gagan V of the gagan so the being there
the uh being in existence and so
intuitions are telling us that that
something really is the case right I
taste the bitter aspirin or actually
that's more sour I suppose right and a
waiver be is it sour is it bitter right
uh I'm I'm doing that because I've
actually got something that I'm tasting
right so then he goes on and he says
well because of this it seems to be
impossible to Intuit it anything a
priori originally because intuition
would have to take place without even
either a former or present object to to
appeal to and therefore it wouldn't be
intuition so this is the very problem
that that he's dealing with and then he
says listen think about Concepts uh that
we can form a priori they contain
nothing but the thought of an object in
general we can universalize or abstract
as as others would say so he says think
about quantity cause but even these he
says in order to be meaningful and
significant can certain uh concrete use
that is an application to some intuition
is needed so this raises a problem how
can the
intuition if it's going to be a priori
precede the object which seems like it
has to be something that we encounter a
posterior through experience how can the
object uh an intuition of the object
precede the object itself so if we can
answer that question then we can say
that a priori intuition
are indeed possible or even actual and
so here's kant's solution here at this
point um he says that if our intuition
had to be of such a nature as to
represent things as they are in
themselves so things is ding right and
we're going to ultimately get to the
ding in zik the thing in itself um and
things as they are in themselves an zek
zst Z as they as they have being as they
exist in themselves and intuition
doesn't have to give us that right he
says that if intuition had to be that
way there wouldn't be any intuition op
priori but intuition would always be
empirical I can only know what's
contained in the object if it's present
and given to me but he
says if even this possibility be granted
an intuition of that sort not take place
a priori before the object were
presented to me so there's only one way
my intuition can anticipate the
actuality of the object and be a
cognition a priori if my intuition
contains nothing but the form not the
content but the form of sensibility Zite
right which in me is a sub object
precedes all the actual Impressions
through which I am affected by objects
now what does this actually mean so if
Kant is right about this then we have
within ourselves you can say your mind
you can say your soul whatever it is
that you want at this point we have this
form of sensibility even before anything
is actually intuited in that sensibility
through imp iCal
experiential a postor
intuitions so now this is a big if isn't
it I mean if you follow K along these
lines then everything falls into place
if you want to deny that you're probably
going to find him
unsatisfying here but let's go along
with this so what would this you know AR
priori intuition that contains the form
of sense
ibility actually contain so he says he
tells us this the intuitions which pure
mathematics lays at the foundation of
all of its cognitions and judgments
which appear at once apodictic and
necessary
are space and time space and time
themselves are not something that you
can directly in it through experience
everything that we int it is in space
that is it's spatially located right in
relation to other things and in time in
this sequence that is moving through but
how do you conceptualize how do you
cognize how do you grasp space and
time themselves do you imagine it sort
of like a big sheet of graph paper where
you've got like a grid on it I mean you
know there that's the way that people
imagine space and time when we're
mapping it at least in terms of space we
have timelines and stuff like that those
are all coming later Kant is telling us
that we as human beings have this a
priori intuition of what it is that
makes it possible to have a posterior or
empirical intuitions at all and you know
mathematics is going to be uh relying
upon this um and like he says both of
these uh representations in geometry and
arithmetic um are merely intuitions if
we admit from the empirical intuitions
of bodies and their alterations that is
motion everything empirical space and
time still remain and are therefore pure
intuitions that lie a priori at the
basis of the empirical hence they can
never be Ed but at the same time by
their being pure intuitions a priori
they prove they are mere forms of our
sensibility which must notice the term
precede come before all empirical
intuition so this you know he says the
problem of the present section is
therefore solved pure mathematics is
synthetic cognition AR priori is
Possible only by referring to no other
objects than those of the senses but
we're not grasping it through the senses
that would be you know empirical
intuition we are sort of cognizing we
are thinking about we're using reason F
to figure out what has to be going on
for us to have um the empirical
intuitions which then you know Applied
Mathematics could be indeed uh you know
connected to right but pure mathematics
is relying on these forms of sensibility
so that is how opary intuitions are
possible which means that pure
mathematics is actually possible as
well
that